good morning believe nation today we're
going to talk about five ways and you
can achieve massive success number one
is my personal favorite and I also
shared my advice at the end of the video
also as you're watching listen along if
you hear something that you really enjoy
that really resonates with you add it to
the comments and put quotes around it so
we know what really has an impact on you
let me share something with you you can
learn all the techniques of the world if
you don't believe in yourself
it won't happen for you I learned all of
it so that's why I do a training called
focus on the seller you've got to focus
on you and as you convince you as you
sell yourself every day every day every
day you will begin to see a difference
in the things that you're doing selling
yourself on your ability to perform a
job to achieve a certain objective
telling yourself every day here I go
again and I got what it takes
this is my day and nothing out here is
going to stop me I'd say don't have a
threat of anybody that worked with the
successful financial athletes people in
politics it's hunger you know you and I
both know intelligence is pretty damn
valuable tool but there are a lot of
very smart people or can't fight their
way out of a paper bag and then when you
find somebody has that Hunger the hunger
that doesn't go away that hunger to be
more to do more to give more that hunger
that never ends you know that's how you
get these people that are the best in
the world at whatever they do and so if
you can oh I think everybody has that
hunger but for some people it's been
asleep for a long time because they're
afraid they're afraid that I'm gonna get
hungry I'm gonna try I'm gonna fail and
so it's human nature to protect yourself
from the fear by just lowering your
expectations but one things I've learned
is you get what you tolerate you get
what you tolerate yourself you get rid
you tolerate in your life and sooner or
later we sometimes hit a point we say
another day another hour this is done
I'm not walking this way I'm not talking
this way I'm not living this way I'm not
gonna be in this relationship anymore
I'm gonna change it and when people do
that that's the beginning of a
breakthrough there's a lot people just
say well I want to get ahead and I say
what does that mean they say well
Brendan I want to make some more money
and I said great make money of what and
they said well I got this job so I'm
gonna try and you know get ahead to hear
this job and I said but is the job but
you really want to be doing in the first
place because sometimes the busy work
that you have in your life isn't your
life's work you know it isn't your real
passion your real Drive your real desire
that your work feels like a hobby it
feels like you get lost into it because
it's so great and so fun and and those
so many people out there lying to
themselves saying well I couldn't make
money at doing X thing you know they
have some big dream they say I couldn't
make money doing that I say we're
talking about
I know yoga instructors making six
figures a year
I know piano teachers making seven
figures per year
you can't go online and not find someone
crushing it in any given topic area of
life today
that there the business opportunity is
there
it's just will you show up in a
disciplined intelligent way which we'll
talk about right so it's becoming
conscious what do you really deeply
truly desire to do because if you get
ahead at things that you don't care
about maybe you're climbing the ladder
or you know you're you're succeeding at
something but it's not your real thing
you know it'll eat at you it'll eat you
from the inside out and it'll deaden the
soul because yeah maybe you have some
financial or material success at that
thing and maybe even have some accolades
maybe people appreciate you for it maybe
even paying people's mortgages and
paying employees at it but if it's not
really your thing then you're in trouble
because you'll never feel internally
like you're getting ahead because you
won't integrate those successes to
yourself because you don't find them
meaningful so getting ahead begins with
becoming conscious - what is it you
truly desire what would you love to do
because you can build a business model
around anything today
that is the great gift of the online
world that is what we've seen over and
over and over worldwide people in any
given area crushing it so what do you
want to do that's where we begin what do
you truly consciously desire to do not
what are you doing because you fell into
it that's not consciousness
consciousness means consciously
designing your life deciding who you are
deciding where you're gonna go and what
you really want to accomplish the second
thing that we have to have do to get
ahead is competence right we have to
have knowledge skill ability in any
given area it's not just one day you
wake up with talent it's that if you're
really going to get ahead you have to
study your craft you have to deeply
study it you know III decided what was
it now 18 years ago that I wanted to
help inspire and motivate people and I
wanted to coach people one on one on
motivation and on high performance and I
wanted to write books on the topics so
18 years ago I started reading a book a
week on psychology leadership
communication marketing and there get on
my hand about human behavior and high
performance I was studying everything I
could in psychology every single week
now it's like people like wait you've
read a book a week for 17 years I don't
brag about I'm not like oh yeah look at
me that was for my passion I knew if I
really wanted to succeed at something I
had to study it and I had to study it
deeply and I couldn't you know spend all
this time doing other things so I had to
study my craft the great artists of our
past history that's what they did they
did one bin they had a true level of
depth of study in that area now maybe
they dabbled in some other areas too but
they became famous because they study in
one area and so what's your area what's
what's the thing you need to study on
develop a deep level of competence into
how to do it and how that world works
because you know we have this saying in
Montana that the time to have the map is
before you enter the woods but a lot of
people have a dream and they run out
into the woods and they just start
trying stuff and they take this path and
this path and this path and this path
and because they didn't study best
practices they sundae with one don't you
know they wake up and they're lost there
used about who they are and where
they're at and they're in this dark
forest of the unknown with no plan to
get out they had no idea they just
jumped into something they didn't study
before taking that leap and I always say
you know it's study pay attention learn
from the best model and most intelligent
smart successful people you can in any
given area that you want to succeed in
in your life before you get into it then
develop competency by doing it over and
over and over and over again don't do it
once in a while here and there over and
over and over that's how you get
competence I mean the reality is reading
a book or going to a conference or
having a great conversation where you
get this golden information that's all
fantastic but what makes mastery is
execution on the ideas not the ideas and
so no idea works unless you're willing
to roll up your sleeves do the practice
invest the time put in the effort do the
work I think we've all observed a lot of
people who they love reading the books
they love showing up at the courses they
do all the online training and nothing
ever changes and they say well you know
I don't know why it doesn't change why
my life doesn't change why my thinking
doesn't change why my performance
doesn't change why my relationships
don't change well it's because ideas
don't work if you don't execute on them
so if you look at the great business
builders you look at any great performer
one thing that makes them great is their
grit one thing that makes them great is
their hunger to practice one thing that
makes them great is they are willing to
sacrifice I mean yes they're passionate
but did you know the root of the word
passion is suffering you've got to be
willing to suffer for your vision you've
got to be willing to suffer to reach BIW
best in world you've got to be willing
to suffer the ridicule and laughter of
your critics and your cynics to get to a
place called world class say on poison a
lot of people stand in front of the
stove of life and they say now stove you
give me some heat then I'll put some
wood in you that ain't the way it works
you got to put something in before you
can get
anything out so many times you know the
employee goes to the employer and say
give me a raise then I'll start coming
to work on time all right
so many times they will come to him and
say make me the boss now I know I
haven't been here very long don't really
deserve to be the boss but I just
function better when I am in charge of
ink you reward me now and then I promise
you I'll learn what this business is all
about later on reward me now and I'll
produce later doesn't work that way
can't you just see a youngster in school
saying teach you if I take a failing
grade home my parents gonna skin me
alive paste me on this quarter and next
time I'll study more than anybody else
reward me now I'll produce later it
doesn't work that way can't you just see
an old farmer standing out in the fields
in October and said Lord I know I didn't
plant a thing this year but if you'll
give me a big crop this year I'll plant
more than anybody next year it ain't
that way folks you gotta put something
in before you can expect to get anything
out well he's just a pump in a way you
know that's hard it's August I mean the
question is just how much pumping are
you gonna do poor I drink the water and
finally Oh Bernard said you know what
Jimmy I don't believe it sending water
down there Jimmy said yeah it is Bernard
you know in South Alabama the wells are
deep it all we're glad they're deep
because the deeper the well the cool of
the cleaner the sweeter the pure the
better tasting the water and isn't that
true of life into that if you can become
an MD by six weeks of summer school that
the rewards would be almost minimal or
nothing and how many paces would you
have ended to that if you become a sales
expert in three days of a training
school or that the rate of pay would go
down rather radically isn't it true that
anything worth doing is worth doing
pearly until you can learn to do it well
we'll never know how many kids have
missed a college scholarship because
they didn't study an average of ten more
minutes a day we will never know how we
come so close to promotion but we're
good discouraged and quit too soon we'll
never know how much more success we
would have had had we just had a little
more pumping in there and pump and pump
and pump and pump well finally Oh
Bernard just got disgust teeth robbers
and you said Jimmy
no wonder down there Jimmy said don't
stop my eyes don't stop if you stop
there what is going to go all the way
back down and then you're gonna have to
start all over the reality is folks and
I'm totally convinced of this this is
the story of America this is your story
this is a story of success this is the
story of life I believe with all of my
heart that if you would pump long enough
and hard enough and enthusiastically
enough that eventually the reward is
going to follow the effort
and then once that water starts to flow
all you got to do is just people to be
steady pressure on it and you're going
to get more water than you can possibly
use so many times people get involved in
something and they'll say well I'll give
it a try and if it works out that'll be
good and it did if it doesn't work out I
mean hang on kill the track you know
what I mean by the way well I gotta tell
you something folks you're gonna pump
forever like that before anything
happens when you get into something grab
that sucker and get with it and then
once the water starts to flow then
ladies and gentlemen
that's what strategies for success is
all about so my quick take on achieving
massive success is that it comes when
you are doing something that you're
really excited about that you're really
passionate about you have to do
something that you love that gets the
creative juices going that you wake up
and you can't wait to do that you fall
asleep you're thinking about that thing
that really ignites you but then you
also have to do it in a new courageous
way you have to do it in a way that is
unique to you because you may want to be
a youtuber as an example your goal is to
be a youtuber and you love making videos
and that's what you're all about and you
can look at my channel somebody else's
Channel and say I want to be exactly
like Evan or I want to be exactly like
Eric Thomas or exactly like you know
Michelle Phan or whoever it is that you
really look up to and that's great in
that you know people before you have
laid the path down for some of the rules
to get to you know where they've gotten
to but you can't just follow somebody
else's path to achieve massive success
at some point yes you can learn from
other people you could take bits from
all these different people that you look
up to but where you will achieve massive
success isn't it doing it in your way or
if you look at the
greatest the people who had greatest
success in any field you look at
athletes you look at the way that
Michael Jordan has had tremendous
success it wasn't doing it the exact
same way that the people before him did
it he had to find a way to live within
the rules of basketball but then find a
way that he could do his own thing and
have his own kind of trademark on the
game that was unique and special for him
and so don't box yourself in you will
not have massive success by only
following somebody else and boxing
yourself in to say I'm just gonna be a
clone of that person I'm gonna do
exactly what they did your massive
success will come when you do something
that you love when you're doing
something that makes you come alive but
then also when you have the courage to
do it differently than anybody before
you has done it that's my take so thank
you guys so much for watching I made
this video because Abdul Majeed asked me
to so if there's a topic you'd like me
to cover in the next edition of believe
life leave in the comments below and
I'll see what I can do I'd also love to
know what are the messages that you've
heard today had the biggest impact on
you and why what change you're gonna
make and why leave in the comments and I
will join in the discussion also if you
see people that have left some of the
remarks in quotes and one of them really
resonates with you make sure to give it
a thumbs up and show them some love
finally in what they give a quick shot
at the Patrick San Chism or cenk ISM
hope I pronounce that okay Patrick thank
you so much for purchasing a copy of my
book it really means a lot to me those
are you guys watching if you want your
chance at a shout out in a future video
make sure to pick up a copy of the book
and email in the receipt so we can keep
track thank you guys so much for
watching have an amazing day continue to
believe or whatever your one word is and
I'll see you soon